cuáles de éstas pertenecen al conjunto
de al conjunto solución de seno de x
igual a un tercio las respuestas están
redondeadas al centésimo más cercano
elige todas las que aplican te invito a
que le pongas pausa el vídeo e intente
resolverlo por tu cuenta
supongo que ya lo intentaste veamos
ahora qué es lo que nos están pidiendo
cuáles son los valores de x cuál es el
conjunto solución cuáles son los
posibles valores de x donde seno de x es
igual a un tercio y para ver esto
dibujemos un círculo unitario un círculo
unitario este es el eje y este de aquí
es el eje x este es x igual a 1 e iguala
1 x igual a menos 1 de igual a menos 1
así es que vamos a dibujar el círculo
que tiene centro en el origen y cuyo
radio y cuyo radio es igual a 1
recordemos entonces cómo se define la
función seno en el círculo unitario si
tenemos un ángulo un lado de un ángulo
déjame hacerlo con un color que lo
puedas ver
un lado del ángulo va a estar sobre la
parte positiva del eje x y xi este es el
otro lado digamos que este es el ángulo
llamémoslo ángulo theta el seno de este
ángulo va a ser el valor de y donde este
lado intersecta el círculo unitario así
es que este valor aquí va a ser seno de
theta con esta revisión hecha veamos
cuáles son los valores de x y estamos
suponiendo que estamos en radiales
cuáles son los valores de x que al
aplicarles la función seno obtenemos el
valor de un tercio en otras palabras
cuando el valor de lleva a ser igual a
un tercio veamos aquí es dos tercios
aquí es un tercio notamos que hay
exactamente dos lugares donde se puede
valer un tercio aquí y aquí así es que
hay dos lugares donde bueno por lo menos
dos en cada vuelta del círculo unitario
después podemos agregar esos valores dos
pi para incluir la vuelta siguiente
vemos entonces que en el círculo
unitario podemos tomar este ángulo este
ángulo de aquí o también podemos tomar
este ángulo
de acá y podemos sumar cualquier
múltiplo de 2 pi a esos dos ángulos y
también va a funcionar también vamos a
obtener que el seno de sus ángulos vale
un tercio veamos entonces cuáles son
estos valores saquemos la calculadora
calculamos entonces el seno inverso
inverso del seno de uno sobre tres y
aquí tenemos que recordar cuál es el
rango de la función seno inverso esta
función nos va a dar valores que van de
menos y medios a pi medios es decir
valores correspondientes a puntos en el
primero y el cuarto cuadrante del
círculo unitario
así es que obtenemos redondeado al
centésimo más cercano 0.34 básicamente
estamos obteniendo que este ángulo de
aquí me de 0.34 y como sabemos que este
este ángulo bueno es un ángulo mayor que
0 es un ángulo menor a pi medios pies
3.14 y fracción y medios es 1.57 y
fracción
así es que el valor de este ángulo es
0.34 radiales
es este ángulo cuánto vale lo podemos
obtener si estamos en la parte negativa
del eje x y le restamos 0.34 que es el
valor de este ángulo este ángulo mide
0.34 y cuánto obtenemos entonces veamos
lo es
el valor de pi menos la respuesta
anterior y esto nos da 2.80 redondeando
al centésimo más cercano así es que
hemos calculado deja de ponerlo con este
color púrpura hemos calculado que este
ángulo es igual a ti menos 0.34 lo cual
es igual a 2.80 radian es redondeado al
centésimo más cercano pero esos no son
todos los valores podemos agregar
múltiplos de 2 y a estos dos valores es
decir pueden ser 2.80 + 2 viene con n
entero con n entero o también puede ser
0.34 + cualquier múltiplo de 2 más 2 y n
con n entero de tal manera entonces que
el conjunto solución vamos a escribirlo
aquí abajo para que estén limpio
el conjunto solución son los valores de
la forma 2.80 + 2 y n con n entero y los
valores de la forma 0.34 + 2 viene con n
entero veamos cuál de éstas es un
subconjunto de las que hemos obtenido
0.34 + 2 tiene con n entero es la que
obtuvimos aquí exactamente sería esta
solución de aquí sin dispositiva vamos
en este sentido llegando al mismo punto
100 es negativa vamos a ir en este otro
sentido llegando al mismo punto así es
que está definitivamente si está en el
conjunto solución 0.34 más viene con n
entero
veamos si estamos en este punto y le
sumamos pi por ejemplo vamos a llegar a
este punto de aquí vemos que
definitivamente esta no es solución pues
aquí el seno vale menos un tercio así es
que esta de aquí no está en el conjunto
solución menos 0.34 corresponde a éste
cuyo seno es menos un tercio si sumamos
un múltiplo de dos y también vamos a
obtener menos un tercio así es que ésta
no es solución lo mismo sucede con esta
que tenemos aquí 2.82 viene en la que
obtuvimos aquí 2.80 nos lleva a esta
posición múltiplos de 2 p implican
vueltas completas así es que esta si
pertenece al conjunto solución
2.80 + pi por n si estás aquí y le sumas
pi por n vas a llegar aquí y el seno de
ese ángulo no es un tercio es menos un
tercio así es que también eliminamos
esta opción así es que las opciones
válidas son estas dos de hecho estas dos
constituyen el conjunto solución de la
ecuación